hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown aside from being
a presidential election year every House
seat is up for grabs in 2020 Republican
Dalia Alec Edie a journalist and Iraqi
refugee is challenging congresswoman
Ilhan Omar in Minnesota's fifth
congressional district
she sat down with host Jessica Rosenthal
to discuss the difficult road ahead as a
first time office seeker Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer's words towards
Supreme Court justices Gorsuch and
Cavanaugh inspired a rare rebuke from
Chief Justice John Roberts Fox News
senior judicial analyst Judge Andrew
Napolitano spoke to Chris foster about
the ongoing war of words between the
High Court and the legislative branch
the Fox News rundown is a Daily News
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to FoxNews podcast.com
i'm shannon bream i'm tom Shalu
I'm Maria Bartiromo and this is the Fox
News rundown Friday March 6th 2020 I'm
Jessica Rosenthal this election year is
not just about Bernie Joe and president
Trump members of Congress will face
challengers including Dalia Alec Edie
who says as a Muslim refugees she can
win the House seat in Minneapolis I'm
the only candidate that could beat al
Hanuman because of my background I am
immune from her brand of identity
politics I'm Chris Foster Chuck Schumer
says he didn't mean it as a threat
telling Supreme Court justices they will
pay the price for anti-abortion rulings
this kind of a personal attack on
members of the court gives the public
the impression that justices are just
politicians in black robes and I'm Gregg
Jarrett I've got the final word on the
fox news rundown
[Music]
it's not all about presidential politics
this year by the time November rolls
around it will also be time for House
elections as well and some high-profile
members of Congress are facing some
interesting challengers Democratic
congresswoman from Minnesota's fifth
District is Ilhan omar elected in 2018
the Muslim Somali refugee fled her
country with her family and came to the
US when she was 12
as of January 2019 she is one of two
Muslim women serving in Congress but
omar has said the promise of America did
not deliver and as congresswoman she
spent a lot of time railing against
President Trump Omar has been accused of
making anti-semitic remarks and of
downplaying what happened on 9/11 she's
also become a target of President Trump
who likes to bash Omar's so-called squad
of three other Congress women including
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes enter Dalia al
akiti one of the many Republicans trying
to unseat Omar she recently spoke at
CPAC the Conservative Political Action
Conference and am using my voice today
to support our president
Donald strong but what she thinks makes
her competitive in this pretty reliably
blue district is her similar background
to Omar's she is also a woman also a
Muslim also a refugee but in this case
from Iraq and she thinks she has a
unique ability to talk to the many
people of color and Somalis who live in
the district the countries that al Haram
are defends like Iran like Qatar like
Turkey they make hostages of their
people before she takes on Omar though
she must first get through a pretty
crowded Republican primary in August we
sat down with Dalia al akiti a reporter
herself to find out what her plan is
since she got elected I was very as a
journalist I wanted to interview her so
I asked my producers we kept trying to
reach out to her and then
um we didn't hear anything from her and
I started coming and spending a lot of
time in Minneapolis because I decided
I've got to talk to her constituents
instead of talking to her and so I spent
a lot of time going back and forth
between DC that's where I live in
Minneapolis until I made the decision
six months ago to move all the time so
it's been it's been a while and did you
move there specifically to take her on
no I was working on a project and I was
doing a research on her and on the
Muslim Brotherhood or non care and and
and all that so that's why I moved and I
started thinking seriously after day
after day until I made the decision in
January to run Ilhan Omar has painted
herself pretty much is the opposite of
President Trump we've seen multiple
press conferences in which she's done
that how much do you plan to tie
yourself to President Trump as you run
in this particular district I'm very
conservative and and my principles are
conservative but at the same time I'm
willing and I will be able to build
broader coalition's and I'm I'm ready to
represent every resident of of that
district regardless of their faith
regardless of their color regardless of
their gender and regardless of their
political affiliation and that's what
the people needs being moderate to talk
to others and building bridges and
building coalitions that what makes
things happen in Congress for that
district what kind of support do you
have in this district because you you
all right like what's the money-raising
situation from people actually in that
district or are you mostly getting
support from conservatives who don't
like Ilhan Omar and those supporters are
coming from outside the district I'm
getting support from inside the district
and outside the thing why am i because
I'm the only candidate that could beat
al Hanuman
because of my background I am immune
from her brand of identity politics she
accuses everybody of being anti this and
anti that and we have similar very
similar background except I love America
she does not before you take on Ilhan
Omar you need to get past your own
Republican primary right I think that's
in August it looks like you've got quite
a few challengers I think the name
Lacey Johnson comes to mind and it looks
like he's raised at least as a end of
2019 quite a bit of money what's what
how are you gonna get past that initial
primary what's the plan lacy has been
living there and have run a couple of
times and lost in state elections so I
don't think he has the the ability to do
so and he's gonna be like any other
challenger he could be an anti-islamic
oh he could be anti Somalis or anti
immigrants and anti refugees etcetera
etcetera so it doesn't make him immune
from her brand of identity politics at
all
plus if we're trying to get someone at
least we need new blood not someone who
ran for a couple of races and and lost
and that's my argument plus I could move
the needle for President Trump in this
district and you'll see tell me a little
bit about your story you are an Iraqi
refugee and of course as you've said a
Muslim woman well it's so sad that I had
to bring all this because I am an
American
after all regardless of any other things
I introduced myself when I traveled as
an American I don't say I'm an American
from blah blah blah of this I'm forced
to use it to neutralize her strategy
is built on hatred and and that's what
she uses so before I am anything yes I
am an American and I'm running as an
American it happened that I am a former
refugee from Iraq but I've been living
here for three decades and I love this
country and that's why I'm here and
that's why I will be here but why did
you leave Iraq tell me a little bit
about your story
well definitely if you live under
tyranny and under oppression and you
have no freedom and especially freedom
of speech and you get executed if you
make a joke or a joke old mark Saddam
Hussein you'll be dead I came here to be
free I came here to have a brighter and
better future and I do have a brighter
and better future and I'm so thankful
for this country that gave me everything
that I want to and I can be whoever I
want without getting scared or feared
from anybody you were here in the United
States when the United States went to
war in Iraq in 2003 when you look back
on that was that decision to go to war
specifically in Iraq a mistake you say
war in Iraq I say the liberation of Iraq
and I will I voted for President Bush
twice and if he runs tomorrow I'll keep
voting for him to thank him for
liberating the Iraqi people from
oppression from tyranny from mass
murderer
you don't feel it people here take
advantage of all the freedoms that they
have because they've never lost it
someone like me who came from such a
brutal run from under the such a brutal
regime I appreciate everything that the
United States has to offer let's get
back to the race for a second back to
congresswoman Ilhan Omar she could get a
big national boost as she ties herself
to Bernie Sanders as he rises she could
benefit sort of off riding those
coattails even financially I mean if
she's a surrogate going out there and
speaking and people know she's facing a
congressional district fight at home
she could get a money boost you know how
do you how do you combat that the first
week we from Americans in 50 states
donated for my campaign and for the
first week we've made $100,000 and
that's from the 50 states that shows you
how much the damage that she's doing and
that shows you that these donors they
believe that I am the one candidate that
could beat her but those donors it
sounds like are coming from outside of
the district how do you convince people
inside the district look this is not a
vanity campaign on my part just to raise
my national profile you know with people
outside of this district you know you do
need to raise money within the district
you do need to compete with Republican
challengers in your actual district and
you it looks like you do have some
competition how do you how do you
convince this particular district and
not national supporters that you're the
person for this job
well from the people I've spoken with
and especially the young professional
who who are living there and who are
suffering from so many things and
especially the security of the of the
district there are more republic
conservative that we we know because
they don't talk about it and we don't
speak about it my argument is I will be
the first four years the first
Republican that could campaign inside
the Somali community and inside the
Muslim community I could speak to that
community and telling them and they know
already what she's doing to every Muslim
American in America she is giving them
she's starting their reputation and they
don't want that
Thursday Elizabeth Warren dropped out
and shortly after that on Twitter
hashtag Biden Warren was trending for a
little bit as you know Joe Biden did
very well
on Tuesday night but Bernie Sanders is
still an obvious contender we've watched
Amy Klobuchar and Pete Budaj and Mike
Bloomberg all drop out when you look at
this race in the context of you running
in in four-seat in November what do you
make of it who do you who do you think
will end up getting this nomination let
me tell you the Democrats are not stupid
and they know the harm that Bernie
Sanders would do to our country and that
so that was quite clear when every
candidate dropped out went behind Biden
the progressive ideas and the socialism
that they were trying to to show Vidal
and I would up our throats it's not
gonna work for people people are not
that naive and they know that we don't
want to be another China we don't want
to be another Cuba we don't want to be
another Venezuela I have one last
question for you you're a Muslim woman
but it looks like you're wearing a cross
yes why that was in 2014 while I was
reporting between Iraq Beirut and London
and that's when Isis entered the city of
Mosul in Iraq and they started
persecuting all the Christians in Iraq
and then that happened in in the whole
region so I'm a TV personality and I
went on air and saying not in my name
I'm the Muslim Sunni I would I'm going
to wear the cross until every Christian
goes back to his village or his home and
this cross I haven't taken it off at all
for the past six years and it became
part of my identity Dalia I luckily
thank you so much for your time thank
you so much for having me
this is Greg Jarrett with your Fox News
commentary
coming out the top Senate Democrat Chuck
Schumer isn't apologizing but says he
used the wrong words about Supreme Court
justices who rule in favor of
anti-abortion cases outside the Supreme
Court at the time and the top Senate
Republican Mitch McConnell says if any
American had these words shouted at them
from a sidewalk outside their office
they would hear those threats as
personal and most likely they would hear
them as threatening or inciting violence
Senator Schumer says he wasn't calling
for violence my point was that there
would be political consequences
political consequences for President
Trump and Senate Republicans if the
Supreme Court with the newly confirmed
justices stripped away a woman's right
to choose Chief Justice John Roberts
called the choice of words inappropriate
and dangerous and there could be a
censure vote expressing Senate
disapproval I think that Senator
Schumer's language was repellent and
dangerous but protected speech Judge
Andrew Napolitano is our senior judicial
analyst at Fox News
it was repellent because of the choice
of words is just so awful you will pay
for this and it was dangerous because
this kind of a personal attack on
members of the court gives the public
the impression that justices are just
politicians in black robes look the
Supreme Court doesn't have an army to
enforce its decisions it bases its its
effectiveness in our society on its
moral suasion when the moral suasion is
undermined because the implicit in
Shermer's argument is these guys made up
their mind before the case got to them
when the moral suasion is undermined it
undermines the court
however for this to be a threat he would
have to have had the present apparent
ability to carry it out at the moment he
ordered it what she didn't and the
Supreme Court has ruled that this type
of speech is protected here's the rule
all innocuous speech is absolutely
protected and all speech is innocuous
when there is time time for more speech
to neutralize a rebutted so some crazy
person in the audience hearing Schumer
somehow immediately breaks into the
court and harms one of those justices
Schumer is liable for incitement but if
a crazy person in Brooklyn aroused by
Schumer drives to DC and tries to attack
the justices Schumer is not liable a lot
of this rawness comes well first of all
it's over these are these a growing
number of abortion cases but a lot of
this rawness is about Mitch McConnell
the Senate Majority Leader stealing from
I can't think of a better word a Senate
Supreme Court justice seat away from
Barack Obama yes I cannot agree with you
more i I don't know how Senator
McConnell had the hutzpah to say what he
said about Chuck Schumer and the role of
the Senate and all of us just kept
thinking about Merrick garland not
getting a vote to refresh the memory of
those listening to listen now Justice
Scalia died Barack Obama was the lawful
president of the United States he
nominated the most conservative nominee
offered by a Democratic president since
FDR nominated Robert Jackson his then
Attorney General to the Supreme Court
many traditionalists in both parties
would have been ecstatic with a justice
Garland Mitch McConnell refused to let
judge Garland's nomination even come for
a vote first time in American history
this happened this began the modern-day
tinkering with the court that manifested
itself into the attacks on Brett
Kavanaugh the senator mcconnell's stated
rash now at the time was there was an
election year that the Supreme Court
seat should somehow be wrapped up in the
election if he feels that way of
this Ginsberg for some reason leaves the
court and he said he said he doesn't he
said that you know you know what if
somebody have something happens this
year President Trump gets to fill that
seat yeah so this is there's no moral a
core here this it's just raw politics
President Trump and the Republican Party
has really gotten their way with his
election filling a lot of these federal
judicial seats with people that they
want in their right do you think that
the Supreme Court and usually in lower
courts are going to be seen now as more
political bodies because we're so aware
of where those seats came from yes and
it's unfortunate because again it
undermines the moral suasion of the
entire court system the president was
actually on to something as awful as the
sounds when he said someone chose an
obama judge and so and so so Trump judge
that's when he was rebuked but Chief
Justice Chief Justice issued two rebukes
in the past three and a half years I
don't know that any rebuke in the
post-world War two ERA by any of his
predecessors one was to the fore
actually three one was to the president
for attacking a judge as a Mexican judge
second was Obama judges versus Trump
judges and the third was to Senator
Schumer anything that undermines the
role of law anything that ignores the
fact and I can tell you this from
personal experience Chris because I was
not a federal judge but a state judge in
one of three state systems we have life
tenure anything that ignores the fact
that when judges have life tenure and
cannot lose their jobs unless they're
impeached for committing a felony the
intellectual freedom and intellectual
honesty causes you to shed your former
political ties Mitch McConnell would say
that it was passed judges that were
acting as activists and that these
appointments are just writing the ship
that that is his argument you know in
the past republic republican presidents
have attempted to appoint judges who
agree with them but they did so
deferring to the senators in both
parties from the states so for example
the Ninth Circuit which serves the 15
westernmost states in every Republican
administration any judge going on the
ninth circuit could be vetoed by any
senator from any state in that circuit
and the California centers would always
veto people that were perceived as too
conservative Donald Trump does not
acknowledge Mitch McConnell does not
acknowledge those those vetoes which has
enabled him to change the Ninth Circuit
for example substantially by packing it
not only with traditionalists
originalist but young traditionalists
and originalist people in their 30s who
will sit for 30 and 40 years well you
know what voters who actually had all
this in mind when they voted for
President Trump are gonna say well good
for us the Democrats the Democrats
should have pushed this issue harder
Trump's argument that elections have
consequences is unassailable and and the
the the choice of who he nominates is
really up to him Senator Schumer says
that he's angry Republicans are trying
to take away abortion rights he said
what he said about the justices during
arguments over a Louisiana
abortion law the law says that all
abortion providers must be licensed MDS
with admitting privileges at a nearby
hospital or other medical facility that
is to preserve the life of the mother
and to preserve the life of a baby who
survives the abortion that was struck
down by the Supreme Court when Texas
enacted it in 2016 after Justice Scalia
died so you had eight members on the
court the vote was five to three one of
the dissenters was the Chief Justice now
you have a different Court Justice
Scalia's been replaced by Justice
Gorsuch who's perceived as being
pro-life and Justice Kennedy has been
replaced by Justice Kavanagh who's
perceived as being pro-life so if those
perceptions are accurate
it's up to the chief justice again is he
going to follow precedent which he
firmly believes in and vote to uphold a
to to invalidate the statute because a
similar statute was invalidated four
years ago or is he gonna vote the way he
voted four years ago which would be to
uphold this passage interesting question
we don't know there is a way out of this
without ruling on the merits and that
would be for the court to say the
plaintiffs don't have standing because
the plaintiffs are not people who want
abortions the plaintiffs are doctors who
fear that their patients will not come
to them any longer because they don't
have admitting privileges at hospitals
in Louisiana such a fanciful fear often
does not constitute standing the right
to sue god we've talked about sanctuary
cities on the podcast a few times I
think the court has now said that the
administration may financially punish
those cities that don't have their
people cooperate with federal
immigration authorities that's other
courts have ruled the other way is this
gonna go to the has to go to the Supreme
Court Chris there there are five Circuit
Court of Appeals decisions on whether or
not the administration can impose a
condition on the delivery of cash to
state and local governments a condition
that did not exist at the time they
accepted the cash the condition the
Trump administration wants to impose is
absolute cooperation with ice
authorities four of those circuit courts
have said you can't impose a condition
as an afterthought the fifth just ruled
last week that's the District of
Columbia Circuit said you can so when
something is lawful in one part of the
country and unlawful in another that's
right for the Supreme Court to resolve
it Fox News senior judicial analyst
Judge Andrew Napolitano a frequent guest
and a friend of the podcast thank you
very much judge pleasure my dear friend
[Music]
if you are enjoying the Fox News rundown
you can listen every day by going to Fox
News podcasts calm and subscribing there
you'll also find exclusive podcast
hosted by some of your favorite Fox News
personalities including Dina Perino Bret
Baier Martha McCallum and Greg Gutfeld
head over to Fox News podcasts calm to
listen and subscribe on your favorite
podcast platform and now some good news
with Tanya J powers chase best is a
coach for the Coradin high school
basketball team in southern Indiana and
has been in need of something for a long
time a kidney recently on senior night
the school honored him showing their
support of kidney disease at the age of
11 has been battling a disease
ever since recently his conditions at
the tea rearrange and became necessary
commune to begin home dialysis free two
men today he is investigating a kidney
transplant tonight if you look around
and our stateís a team
poor kid audio courtesy of cord and
Central Athletics the announcement was
also an effort to get the word out about
organ and bone marrow donation as the
crowd sat on the bleachers in the small
gymnasium listening to the announcement
many of the board green and support of
Chase instead of the school colors of
black and gold Chase and his family
stood at center court and his former
baseball coach came out chase was given
a t-shirt which he looked at and
surprised his baseball coach was a
perfect match
it was life-saving news for Chase and
now his family is encouraging others to
sign up to be possible donors if you'd
like more information on the website
they referenced to go to be the match
dot org Tonya J powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
read Jared what's on your mind
good luck deposing Hillary Clinton
she'll figure out a way to circumvent
the truth
it's her greatest skill set Clinton and
her attorneys have spent months
inventing one excuse after another for
why she shouldn't have to sit for a
deposition answering questions about her
unauthorized unsecured computer system
she used a secret server to handle all
of her electronic communications as
Secretary of State including thousands
of classified and top-secret documents
there's no doubt that Clinton's
unprotected email apparatus jeopardized
America's national security the State
Department eventually divulged there had
been at least 30 separate security
breaches Chinese intelligence reportedly
gained access to her server housing
classified documents did the Russians
penetrate the same system you can bet on
it
thus Hillary Clinton almost certainly
committed a myriad of felonies under the
Espionage Act and other criminal
statutes instead of pastel pantsuits
Clinton should be wearing an orange
jumpsuit but the Obama administration
protected her allowing former FBI
director James Comey to clear her by
twisting the facts and contorting the
law to his great credit US District
Court Judge Royce Lamberth is refusing
to let that be the last word he ordered
Clinton to sit for a deposition to
answer questions about her email server
in a years old lawsuit brought by the
conservative watchdog group Judicial
Watch judge Lamberth is wise to the
artistry of
Hillary Clinton's evasion techniques he
called her prior responses to questions
incomplete unhelpful and cursory at best
throughout the course of her email
scandal Clinton attempted to cover up
what she had done by peddling
Civ series of errant deceptions five
different stories all of them proven to
be untrue during Clinton's FBI
interviews she abandoned all those
excuses in favor of amnesia she replied
I do not recall or I don't remember some
39 times she was not placed under oath
and was cleared by James Comey three
days later solidifying the charade the
notorious FBI agent Peter struck later
fired by the bureau participated in the
softball questioning
there will be no softballs lobbed at
Clinton when she's deposed by lawyers
for Judicial Watch but if past is
prologue she will be a shifty witness
beyond remembering her name and date of
birth Clinton will feign total memory
loss akin to acute dementia sadly it
will all be a waste of time I'm Gregg
Jarrett Fox News be sure to pick up my
new book witch hunt the story of the
greatest mass delusion in American
political history
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios hourly newscast at
FoxNews podcasts dot-com and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
[Music]
love Fox News click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes